now then here's a fact for you maybe for
a pop quiz usually happens about four
times a century Hanukkah and Christmas
fall on the same day this year in a
week's time and in another sign of good
relations the chief rabbi has launched a
new interfaith initiative aimed at
improving ties between religions at the
grassroots level well chief rabbi Mervis
joins me now and a very good morning to
monitor what tell me about this only for
time is essentially Hanukkah and
Christmas falling on the same day why is
that it's pretty rare we have a lunar
based calendar which is affixed to the
solar system now that sounds quite
complex and as a result we have seven
leap years every 19-year cycle and that
means the addition of an additional
month consequently Hanukkah takes place
in November December every year on
different dates of the Gregorian
calendar and it's very rare for the
first day of the eight-day festival of
Hanukkah to coincide with Christmas and
it's happening this year
well like joy be unconfined I'm sure it
well thank you very explaining that them
and write that down in records tell me
tell me chief rabbi about the this
interfaith initiative you've been
meeting with amongst others the
Archbishop of Canterbury well the
Archbishop of Canterbury and I we work
closely together in many ways and last
month we launched the in good faith
initiative it's wonderful we brought
together 70 rabbis and priests from
around the country for a day-long
seminar in Lambeth Palace the idea is
that they could meet their counterparts
discuss key issues with them and as is
the case with every good initiative it's
the follow-up
it's the durability of the project which
counts and so these rabbis and priests
and I will be collaborating together
within their regions to guarantee that
they work together in the future
okay but people are going to say right
you know warm words you're getting
together and all believing that you know
the world should be a nicer place but
you have to get out there and you're
talking about doing things
doing what ah doing an enormous amount
social responsibility visiting each
other making joint statements
understanding where each other are
coming from there are various topical
issues sometimes there have been
difficulties and
through two high log we can understand
people better is this just Christians
and Jews or are you reaching out to some
of the many other faiths represented in
the UK this particular initiative is the
Jewish community together with the
Anglican community I work very closely
with Cardinal Vincent Nichols as well
and the Catholic community and we have
some wonderful organizations involving
the world of Islam such as the three
faiths forum and also the Council of
rabbis and priests and many other
organizations around the country well
tell me what that experience tells you
and given events of the last well year
and few years in the United Kingdom
about social cohesion and about you know
lots being mentioned about anti-semitism
about hate attacks have you seen that
that grow and then diminish this year or
stay about the same tell me the last
year has been a worrying one with regard
to anti-semitism it's also been an
encouraging one it's being worrying
because levels of anti-semitism in the
continent and in Britain have
unfortunately risen together with that
both on behalf of the government and the
judiciary we've seen some very welcoming
moves the announcement by Teresa made
last week that the government is going
to adopt the ihr a definition of
anti-semitism is something my HR a
international Holocaust Remembrance
Alliance and this is a clear definition
that the government is going to adopt
and I was very pleased that the Labour
Party almost immediately endorsed the
announcement of the government and will
likewise be accepting this definition
but you weren't too pleased with him
were you not / pleased with their
dealings with allegations of
anti-semitism amongst some of its
membership and then they're either Shami
Chakrabarti review that they held this
year has been one of deep disappointment
in that regard however recently there's
been a lot of constructive talking
coming from the leadership of the Labour
Party
now that the ihr a definition of
anti-semitism has been endorsed by the
party we're entering into 2017 which is
a year
crying out for action and that's what we
hope to see and while we're on that that
issue let me broaden it out from
anti-semitism when you hear disc
within society within a country which
starts to to question the role of
foreign people of others more broadly
and it's not just happening in in our
own country do you think that gives some
people a license then to indulge in in
anti-semitism they interpret they
interpret those signs in that way
anti-semitism is the oldest hatred and
nobody has yet succeeded in pinpointing
where does it come from and what is it
actually all about you know it's it's
the biggest problem that we face however
we need to confront it education is a
key and also having the right kind of
legislation setting the right tone
within society preventing and dealing
with instances that is very important
and I'm heartened because throughout
2016 going around the UK so many people
voluntarily came up to me to say we're
embarrassed by what is happening
we totally disassociate ourselves from
it this is not the real UK and I believe
that they're right and also you getting
out there as well so to speak you tell
me very quickly about an initiative you
had another initiative yeah amongst I'm
so excited it's the Boehner's I program
taking place next week my wife and I
were in India at the beginning of this
year we entered into the slums in
addition to visiting Jewish communities
there we were so taken by what we saw
and we came back to the UK and we said
we've got to do something
and so we've launched the Benassi
program next week 16 top Jewish
University students will be going to the
slums in Mumbai they'll be working there
and from their experiences they'll be
coming back to the UK to be our
emissaries for social responsibility
within the nation because they are going
to make a statement that it's a core
part of Jewish religion that we don't
only concern ourselves with ourselves
but we reach out to all others we see
the divinity within every single soul
chief rabbi rabbi Mathis very good to
see you happy Chanukah thank you